breast reconstruction helps restore
the appearance of the breast after a
mastectomy it can be performed at the time of the
mastectomy or some time later you and
your surgeon will choose What type of
reconstructive surgery is best for
you your choices will usually
include or a synthetic implant  or one
of the following two procedures
using your own tissue to
reconstruct your breast Latissimus dorsi muscle flap
or An abdominal muscle flap
which is also called a
tram flap before the procedure an
intravenous line will be administered and
you may receive an oral sedative
to help  for
breast reconstructions to be performed under
anesthesia you will be BMD during the
surgery and will be intubated through your
mouth and throat to help you breathe
during the
operation
for the Latissimus Dorsi Muscle Flap
your surgeon will make an incision in the
thoracic region  Separate a section of tissue and
wrap the Flap at the point of
mastectomy A
transverse rectus abdominis myocutaneous flap or tram
begins with your surgeon making an
incision in the skin of the
chest then he will make an
elliptical incision in the skin, fat and
muscle of the abdominal wall or  if
there is not enough tissue in the abdomen in the lower
back then the surgeon will slide
the tissue under the skin to the
mastectomy site to form a bulge
in the breast, great care must be taken to
maintain the blood supply to the
bulge
reconstructed finally your surgeon
will suture the incision in the thoracic
or
abdominal region the tissue flap procedure
is similar whether it is performed
immediately some time after the
mastectomy the synthetic implant procedure
however Depends on the timing
of the
reconstruction sear by the implant at the
time of the mastectomy your surgeon
will insert it immediately after  remove the
breast tissue and suture the incision
if you choose to have
implant surgery later your skin may have to
be stretched before reconstruction can be
performed in this case your surgeon will
reopen the mastectomy incision and
insert a balloon tissue expander
After a period of a few weeks your
surgeon will stretch the skin and
breast skin by injecting
salt water into the exposed tissue
during Second operation your surgeon will
make another incision remove the
tissue expander insert a permanent synthetic implant
and suture the
cut after surgery the intubation will be
removed and you will be taken to the
post-surgical recovery area for
monitoring.
breast is
complete you may decide to have
your nipple and area reconstructed this
procedure is relatively simple and
can be performed in your doctor's office
in 30 to 60 minutes There are different
types of nipple reconstructions but a
common type involves removing the  tissue
from your inner thigh or ear to
create a small nipple-shaped protrusion
which can be tattooed to
better fit the natural nipple and
areola this replacement nipple is attached to the
central area of ​​the breast reconstruction